2014 saw the release of the long end
development South Park the stick of
truth again that to us proved that you
can make a good game based on a TV show
and also live up to the lofty
expectations of your fanbase last week
we're going to hands-on with the sequel
South Park the fractured but whole which
trades wizards and knights for
superheroes and villains you can
subscribe to us on YouTube so you don't
miss any of our gameplay clips from the
session but for now here is 5 cool
things we learned about that plug the
fractured behold and also this is for
mature audiences only combat is more
strategic but it can get repetitive
you'll immediately notice that combat is
way more involved this time around
you'll still engage in turn-based combat
with the team and you'll need to execute
a well-timed button presses to unleash
attacks but it's a little more
complicated than that you're now able to
move around the battlefield laterally
and vertically during your turn in a
fight this is particularly important as
your characters have different attacks
in which targets specific areas of the
gridded battlefield same goes for your
foes some attacks will also unleash
extra effects such as knock back which
you can use to hit an extra enemy if
your foes are situated just right on top
of that this time around you can unlock
12 classes which include brutalist
mystic cyborg and karate kid' i mean you
are a super hero after all
your choice will grant you different
abilities which lend themselves to
different fighting styles and team make
ups that said dan and I found that more
often than not we gravitated toward
using the same abilities in most
scenarios even though we each picked
different classes so combat does begin
to feel a little repetitive particularly
when some of the Townies are simply a
lot more useful than others to have on
your team it's like watching South Park
from the very beginning the fractured
but whole will make you laugh with
signature South Park humor in a
character creator for instance messing
with the difficulty slider changes your
character's skin tone white for easy and
black for hard it's not the real
difficulty slider in the game but it's
played for laughs and like so much of
the games comedy at least from the three
hours we played even though it made us
cringe it still really really works
running into characters from the show
usually triggers a cutscene that is
indiscernible from an episode of South
Park
obviously retelling the game's jokes is
the worst way to experience comedy so
here's a select few moments from what
played [ __ ] you mom you want to play the
game would you just want to be known as
a smoke cheating [ __ ] the right here
that exploration is rewarding just like
last time the town of South Park is free
for you to explore with a bunch of
brand-new places to visit and people to
meet and occasionally be horrified by
inside every location you'll find chests
cupboards and trash cans full of
crafting items that are references to
the show
seriously if you thought there are a lot
of references in the first game it feels
like the sequel is well and truly
doubling down you can use these items to
craft consumables to aid you in battle
something the town's crafting master
Morgan Freeman will teach you at its
taco stand congratulations new kid with
an enchilada and a burrito you've
crafted an injury dough that's the first
time anyone's ever done that finding
your way into the game's nooks and
crannies will also reward you with money
which you can use to buy things to wear
or wield $20 can buy many peanuts wrong
show oh no TV censors means way more
stuff stuff if you're not a fan of South
Park's particular brand of humor you're
gonna have a bad time with fractured but
whole because it feels like everything
has been dialed up to 11 here's what I
mean
after a short prologue that recaps the
stick of truth while setting up the
sequels stakes you as the new kid must
find a way into Cartman's basement aka
the Coons lair after unsuccessfully
trying to hack my way in using phrases
like shot my donkey balls and you pee my
balls donkey I eventually made my way
upstairs and found his Trapper Keeper
inside was the correct password you mum
as well as several extremely graphic
homoerotic drawings of Kyle now you know
why we said this video was for mature
audiences later on in the demo a section
found us locked in the back room of the
South Park Church and it's hacked by
pedophilic priests with a fetish for
self-flagellation and anal beads
Ubisoft certainly don't seem to have put
any restraints on letting South Park
creators Trey Parker and Matt Stone do
what they do best so it's probably safe
to say the rest of the game will likely
feature a lot more of these moments it's
still embracing being an RPG something
that really excites me about the South
Park game is how much the developers
seem to care about making sure this
isn't just a good South Park game but a
fully-realized RPG given the addition of
classes and cry
as well as your expensive inventory and
equipment screens the fractured but
whole looks to be an even deeper RPG
than the first game there are a ton of
mainline quests and side quests to keep
you busy and the world is littered with
collectables and puzzles from fetch
quests that require you to collect X
amount of a certain item two times
specific events that require you to
return at a particular time of the day
there's a wide variety of stuff to get
involved in and it's all been sucked in
south park flavor we actually played way
past our allotted time session for this
preview and I can say like for what
we've played so far we really enjoyed it
yes speak to the entire game just yet
but if it's anything like the demo I
think we're in for a treat
there's something else that I think is
worth noting is that while it has a lot
of vulgar humor and really pushing the
envelope with its jokes it also
perfectly captures the imagination of a
kid playing Super Heroes and that's
something that South Park has always
done so well yeah fingers crossed by the
end of this one we'll be saying I think
we learned something today
but do you think your comments in the
comment section let it serve what you
think of this one and stay tuned to game
spot for everything gaming thanks for
watching a warm tortilla wrapped around
well any old something here I'll give
you what you need to get started this
here shows how much food you need to
fill up that tortilla now to just put it
all together